Vida sidorkina is a Russian Victoria's
Secret model turn lifestyle content
creator documenting everything from her
model workouts aesthetic morning
routines makeup tutorials and of course
what she eats she's also recently shared
her personal Journey healing her
relationship with food after suffering
from an eating disorder while growing up
emerged in the modeling world but Vita
is now a new mom and has a fresh new
perspective on fueling her body and food
so let's take a look at everything she
eats in a day hey everyone I'm Abby
sharp welcome to Abby's kitchen
foreign
[Music]
eats in a day and of course please pause
the screen or look at the description to
check out my disclaimer including a
trigger warning to those with current or
previous experiences with disordered
eating we will be talking about eating
disorders in some details so please feel
free to skip this video if it's not
supportive to your journey and if you're
not already subscribed here guys help a
YouTuber out hit that subscribe button
and follow me on Tick Tock and Instagram
at Abby's kitchen okay so as a brief
backgrounder Vita started modeling at
the ripe age of 13 and eventually went
on to walk the coveted albeit highly
controversial Victoria's Secret Fashion
Show in 2015. but this career Milestone
wasn't without its consequences as Vita
fell into the throes of anorexia in the
process of earning her wings fast
forward to today and Vida is now a
mother to daughter Allegra who has made
a point to embrace intuitive eating and
make peace with food after distancing
herself from the modeling world so let's
take a closer look at what intuitive
eating looks like for Vita post Ed
recovery
foreign
okay so just a quickie shot here and not
a lot of commentary but honestly if it
means we get to avoid typical
influencers pseudoscience claims I am
here for that now I've seen Vita mention
in some of her other videos that she
will often swap her morning coffee for
matcha particularly around her period
because coffee tends to make her feel a
little more jittery and anxious during
that time of the month I actually taking
a break from a coffee because I do feel
like coffee sometimes keeps up on me and
I feel a little agitated especially when
I'm around my period And I already like
have my nerves on the edge kind of
switching it to a green tea or a tomato
and this is actually evidence-based
since Shark Week is accompanied by
progesterone and estrogen declines which
makes us a little more susceptible to
anxiety and irritability not to mention
even though the caffeine content in
matcha is comparable to that in in
coffee it does tend to have a more Slow
Burn effect thanks to the amino acid
l-theanine as for the rest of this
breakfast we're getting a big dose of
antioxidants and fiber-rich carbs from
the acai Bowl which is great for post
Pilates but most are pretty low in
protein and fats and we know how
important protein is for morning satiety
and also for post-workout recovery
especially if we're going to be working
out fasted so if we want to make it into
a more balanced meal I would maybe opt
for a yogurt or protein powder based
bowl or top it off with like lots of
hemp parts or nut butter as I've seen
Vita do in other Clips we are about to
eat lunch I honestly not a breakfast
person as you already know but this
morning I had a breakfast smoothie with
my friend after a workout so I'm not
very hungry but I still want to eat
something because I know if I just
stretch more time I'll get really hungry
we love this explanation so Vitas
previously explained on her channel that
she isn't usually hungry until around
11AM so she generally waits to eat
breakfast until then this doesn't seem
like a sneaky dieting tactic or an
attempt at intermittent fasting for
health especially since she's previously
said that she avoids intermittent
fasting at a concern for her hormonal
Health PS if you want to learn more
about the relationship between interim
fasting and female hormones I have a
whole video you can check out right here
but yeah she clearly seems flexible
about this since she had a light
breakfast in like a social eating
situation and I've seen in other wedding
today videos where she did have
breakfast or a morning snack so I would
say in vida's case specifically it makes
total sense not to want like a more
hearty protein and fat Rich breakfast so
I just want to reiterate that if you
aren't hungry first thing in the morning
or you aren't hungry for like a full
balanced meal and you're truly giving
yourself unconditional permission to eat
without restrictions then follow your
intuition like don't eat breakfast have
your first meal when it feels best for
you sure they may be some small
metabolic benefits to like front loading
our calories to earlier on in the day
when we're more sensitive to insulin but
what we eat over the course of a few
days or weeks is way more important than
when we eat it what all this unnecessary
Cravings I'm not a person that's next so
I don't like snacks so I prefer like a
proper meal okay so without breakfast
and without snacks we're really only
left with two meals in the day and that
may genuinely feel good to Vida and her
body but I also just want a flag that it
can be very difficult to meet our bodies
energy and nutrient needs from just two
meals in a day especially if we're
throwing in a daily workout into that
mix this is actually one of the issues
that we often run into with intermittent
fasting because not only do limited
eating opportunities make it difficult
to eat enough calories to meet our needs
but it's also challenging to eat enough
protein to supply support Muscle
Recovery since our bodies utilize on
average around 20 to 35 grams of protein
per sitting depending on your body size
for muscle protein synthesis so assuming
Vita's meals provide this amount of
protein it would only be enough to
support her basic needs let alone muscle
building in which case she would
absolutely want to be adding in an extra
meal or snack I do want to add here that
most of the wedding a day videos that
I've watched from Vita do include three
to four meals or snacks so it's very
possible that she just was like less
hungry on this day or maybe this no
snacking thing is new I don't really
know but as a model influencer sharing
her diet openly I do think we need to be
responsible for what we share and maybe
just throw in something like hey I guess
I didn't eat as much today as usual
folks because a lot of people watching
will assume that they too should be
skipping breakfast and snacks and for
most folks it's it's just not going to
be enough we're going to make like a
really green healthy salad which I kind
of craved some greens today love a model
who isn't afraid of oil or carbs and
this lunch looks absolutely delicious
we've got healthy fats from the avocado
nuts and olive oil a bit of carbs from
the corn plus protein from the smoked
salmon now she previously explained that
she chooses vegan cream cheese because
she prefers The Taste and seeing as the
nutritional profile is basically
identical to that of regular cream
cheese I think it makes total sense here
choosing food for flavor is great
evidence of non-diet intention so yeah I
feel like we need to do like a vegan and
dairy-based taste test right now leave
me a comment below with your thoughts
just marinate a little bit so you can
have a little glue prep everything in
cookware literally five minutes to do it
all out
foreign
[Music]
we love involving our kids in meal prep
which can help to improve new food
acceptance and body autonomy and let's
be real most of us moms can't say that
their kids like fish scalloped potatoes
Olive spinach and goat's cheese so Bravo
Mama like keep up that regular exposure
plus this meal is super nutrient Rich
we've got healthy fats from the walnuts
olives and olive oil carbs from the
potatoes lots of fiber and
micronutrients from the veggies and
greens as well as protein in the fish
this food is also obviously flavor
packed which is a key consideration when
building a satisfying meal we love to
see it now before we close off I do want
to expand a bit on vida's eating
disorder experience and what she said in
her video about making peace with food
and her body so for some background Vita
suffered from anorexia working in the
modeling industry at age 15. when she
was told that she would need to lose
weight in order to succeed when she
decided that she desperately wanted to
book the Victoria's Secret show she took
some pretty drastic and dangerous
measures trigger warning folks there are
some images in this next clip of her at
a very low body weight so please skip
ahead if that's triggering for you so I
worked so hard and starved myself for
the entire year to be on the show for
the next year and I made it and that's
kind of my second time that I was at the
lowest weight you can see the picture
here do I regret being there and do it
no because I think I would regret for
the rest of my life not giving it a shot
and not giving it all okay so this is a
short clip in a much more nuanced
conversation and in the video she kind
of like flip-flops in His Wish washy on
how to approach or answer that question
but regardless that little clip there
suggesting that it was not a regret
suggesting perhaps that in some ways it
was worth it really should have been
edited out this does not seem like a
good message to put out into the world
especially considering Vita is now a mom
to a young girl herself who was one day
potentially going to watch all of this
footage of her mom and her online which
you guys know I take issue with but that
is a whole other story but anyways
listen the modeling industry is toxic as
and she acknowledges this quite a bit in
her video which I really appreciate but
that doesn't mean that we need to be
okay with it it doesn't mean that we
need to tell our girls that it's worth
it and not a regret to damage our young
bodies and Minds to reach some kind of
goal she was taught this message by
someone by many people in her life and I
think it does a lot of young women out
there a huge disservice to be taught it
again you know Veda maybe survived her
anorexia and she should be proud of how
far she's come but I want to remind
everyone that anorexia is the number one
psychiatric killer period other young
people are not so lucky to recover and
Escape so like would she tell her
daughter that she would not regret not
starving herself to give herself the
best shot at a mod career I assume she
would not because it's harder for us to
protect ourselves than it is to try to
protect those that we love but when we
have a public platform like this we need
to treat everyone watching kind of like
our children we need to care we need to
be responsible for our words so I am
thrilled for Veda that she made it to
the other side and I even appreciate her
giving tips and inspiring others in
their recovery but I do think it's
potentially very damning for a beautiful
model turned mom who arguably has a
socially determined perfect body to say
anything other than it was absolutely
not a risk worth taking because this
outcome that we see here on the screen I
mean she reached a goal she recovered
seemingly unscathed she had a baby and
she still drop dead gorgeous will never
be how most people's Journeys look so
yeah just some more food for thought but
on that note that's all that I have for
you guys today if you like this video be
sure to give it the thumbs up please a
big reminder to be kind in the comments
but leave a comment below on who or what
you'd like to see me review next
subscribe to the channel and I'll see
you next time on Abby's kitchen bye
[Music]